hello i'm wolfgang puck and today i'm
gonna do a version of a recipe my mother
taught me called kaiserschmann as a kid
in austria we had our own chicken so we
had to go and get the eggs in the bun we
had them really super fresh so the
vanilla bean has seeds inside this is
where all the flavor is but if you can't
get it fresh get a bottle of vanilla i
make kaizajman with my son oliver and
alexander for their mother my wife
so we can serve it to her in bed now if
you're lucky enough you get it served in
bed that's the ultimate
when i grew up in austria we didn't have
electricity in our house and we baked in
a wood burning oven and you know often
now these days we get back to do it
really traditional the old-fashioned way
look at that beautiful egg whites with a
soft peak you see this thing here you
turn it over and it slightly bends over
we want a fluffy and light kaiserschmann
so we're gonna fold in the rest of the
egg whites
you can use any kind of molds you like
the most important thing is though you
have to butter that and sugar that be
sure to have it everywhere the great
thing with kaiserschmann is you can
prepare it in the morning keep it in the
refrigerator and then just cook it at
the last moment now i'm gonna warm up
the strawberries i like strawberries but
in austria we don't have a lot of
strawberries maybe for one month so we
use a lot of plums my mother used to
make plum compote with a little orange
juice or little lemon juice and served
it without kaiserschmidt see how nice
and fluffy our
man
is here perfect
if you make that for mother's day your
mother will feel like a queen it is so
delicious so happy mother's day to all
the mothers around the world
oh yes